sam and bob are looking for a job and
bob got the job but sam is facing some
problems and is worried about the job
with this problem is walking on a road
suddenly bob saw sam and asked hi sam
where are you going nothing just for a
regular walk you seem to be worried
about something and what it was i was
worried that i got disqualified in the
coding interview then why are you
worried about that be prepared for the
next time by visiting simply launch
video hey do you mean that video on tips
to track a coding interview yeah exactly
watch that video then you should get an
idea of how to prepare for the next
interview sam thanks for the suggestion
man you're always welcome hey everyone
welcome to yet another exciting video
from simply learn in this session we
will be discussing some important tips
to track a coding interview however
before we begin this session make sure
that you have subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon so that you can never miss an
update from simply learn so first let us
understand the first step to crack the
in interview that is the job description
before we apply for a job we must be
clear about the role when you get an
idea and clarity about these things then
it is easy to prepare for yourself for
an interview and feel better to get job
easily now let us move to the next one
and the second one in the dot is
research about the company when we go
for an interview most of the people just
look and research the job rule and
responsibilities but no one researches
about the company researching about the
company helps to get an idea about the
works and projects done till date it
also helps to get brief idea about the
jobs and skills required for the company
when we are clear about all these things
it is simple to crack the coding round
and impress the interviewer easily now
let's go into the next one so the third
one in the list is good coding knowledge
before going to a coding interview you
must be clear about your coding skills
these play a massive role in cracking
the coding interview the entire round
depends on these skills so before you
give a coding interview get prepared
well for the interview many websites and
online resources are available to get an
idea of what questions would be asked in
the interview there are some questions
available based on the company interview
process on the internet there are many
websites and online resources available
on the internet to get an idea of what
questions would be asked in the
interview there are some questions
available based on the company interview
process on the internet these help and
impact more in qualifying the interview
now the next one in the list is practice
coding interview questions this step is
for the people who participate in a
coding interview without enough practice
practicing is the key to improve and
upgrade knowledge in a person they help
to build knowledge and improve skills
quickly and effectively when you
practice more on coding you gain more
knowledge and experience on coding when
these skills are developed much in you
it is easy to crack a coding interview
now the next round in the list is good
communication skills communication
skills help a lot in finding a job these
skills are much needed to communicate
with the interviewer and help to get a
good impression about you on your skills
when you work under a team there is a
huge requirement where you have to
communicate with other team members and
this would help you to upscale your
knowledge as well if you are good at
your communication it is much easier for
you to find a job in a company you're
looking for now the next one in the list
is the body language before going to any
interview most of the people tend to
worry about their interview will they be
suitable for the job role or will their
skills be good enough or will they be
good enough to finish the interview well
this happens because of the confidence
in them most of the times they lack the
confidence when the people are much more
confident it is easy for them to feel
better about the interview while giving
the interview you must wear proper dress
you should be informals and then the
interviewer will get a good impression
on you and you should be polite enough
till the entire interview process
positivity helps you gain and boost your
confidence in an interview so you must
be confident in yourself before going
for any interview followed by that the
next important tip is self introduction
before you walk into the interview room
you must be prepared about how to start
your introduction keep in mind that the
introduction should attract the
interviewer and make him understand
about you in a short amount of time you
must include your entire information in
a short description and mention your
professional background properly it
includes your skills your experience and
your educational background as well now
let us understand the final tip for the
session so the final tip is dress formal
appearance is an essential tip to get a
good impression on you so before you go
for a coding interview be informal when
you dress formally it grabs the
interviewer's attention and also you'll
feel comfortable while giving the
interview when you look comfortable in
your attire it is quite easy for the
interviewers to make the interview
happen quite comfortably and this was
all for today's session i hope now you
guys have got a brief idea of how to
crack a coding interview if you find
this information helpful to make your
interview successful please subscribe to
our youtube channel and don't forget to
hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn if you have any
questions then please feel free to let
us know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be happy to
resolve all your queries until next time
thank you for watching stay tuned for
more from simply learn and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here